en Atlanta las manifestaciones contra la
construcción de un centro de
entrenamiento policial continúan el
domingo 23 personas fueron detenidas
cuando en una protesta mayoritariamente
pacífica un grupo comenzó a lanzar
piedras y bombas incendiarias al lugar
de las obras
como ya he dicho en otras ocasiones el
terrorismo doméstico no será tolerado en
este estado Mientras seguimos respetando
las protestas pacíficas también
continuaremos garantizando la seguridad
en nuestras comunidades la comunidad
rechaza la construcción del centro por
considerar que Atlanta se convertirá en
lo que los manifestantes llaman una
copcity o ciudad de la policía esto en
medio de pedidos nacionales a reformar
Una institución con constantes denuncias
de violencia ante sus filas también
porque la construcción del centro supone
la destrucción de 34,4 hectáreas de un
importante bosque para la ciudad de 6
millones de habitantes
ignorando los gritos de los residentes
la ciudad de Atlanta se mueve para
destruir el bosque urbano más grande y
reemplazarlo con la instalación de
entrenamiento policial militarizada más
grande de América del Norte
los activistas han acampado durante
semanas cerca a donde se realizan las
obras y han realizado diversas
manifestaciones contra la construcción
con constantes enfrentamientos con la
policía en enero uno de los activistas
Manuel Esteban Páez Terán de 26 años
falleció en un tiroteo de agentes
policiales